one two three four scientists have long
wondered why humans like music and why
we're so good at making it our love
affair has deep roots even our closest
primate cousins have been seen banging
out riffs in the wild but what makes
music music scientists have identified
18 so-called music universals six of
them are related to rhythm they include
a steady beat a preference for two and
three beat groupings regular weak and
strong beats and the use of beat
patterns to construct riffs the
universals came from 304 recordings of
music around the world but do they hold
up when people invent music from scratch
to find out scientists asked
non-musicians to play a game of
telephone the first person tried to
imitate random drumming noise from a
computer
the second person tried to imitate the
first by the time the final person laid
down their riffs something amazing
happened the random beats had
transformed into easy to learn highly
structured patterns that reflected all
six universals this says scientists
might not explain why we like music it
might help explain how our brains are
wired to produce it great
[Applause]
[Music]